this is Thomas I I love this Photograph
uh it has these fingerprints visible
upon it we don't know whose they are
they may be Thomas's they may be Helens
and the lines of the fingerprints are
picked up in the lines of this big baggy
tweed jacket that Thomas liked to wear
he had many of them they smelt of smoke
because he smoked his clay pipe and he
liked big pockets on them so he could
fill them with hazelnuts and apples
apples as he walked
um if you know of Thomas you probably
know of him as a first world war poet
and you probably know of him as the
author of such often anthologized and
nationally favored poems as as the
team's head brass or probably most
famously adelstrup yes I remember Adel
strop
well lots of people do nearly a century
on from its writing and Thomas really
because of that one poem
has been remembered as a quiet
pastoralist as a as an allergist for an
old England that was was dying even as
he wrote in the Years running up to the
war
if you go to the British Library
exhibition in fact wastelands to
Wonderland's uh some of you will have
done you'll find Thomas in the rural
dreams room which seems emblematic of
the way he's largely remembered there's
a first early draft of adults drop there
a rural dreamer he wasn't uh he was many
things and rarely if ever that he was a
novelist he was a memoirist he was a
short storyist he was a biographer he
was a travel writer he was a truly great
nature writer he was a walker he was a
depressive he was a passionate friend
and often poor husband a brilliant but
also cruel parent to his children and he
was profoundly modern very long before
his time
some of you will know the story of his
coming to poetry came very late in his
life urged into it by his friend the
American poet Robert Frost and he wrote
very fast he wrote around 140 poems in
just over two years he started in
December 1914 and he stopped early in
just in 1917 and these really were poems
that changed the course of English
language poetry and their Branch lines
are still being followed Ted Hughes
famously said at one point Edward
Thomas's father of us all
and in those poems and in his prose and
in his life he was obsessed I think with
one question above all and that question
was how we are affirmed and Scattered by
how we are consoled and troubled by the
Landscapes through which we move and the
places in which we live
that's really why I've begun tonight
with Thomas and I will end with him as
well because I want to talk to you as I
say about this fugitive subject of these
relations
unmistakable to experience very
difficult to articulate between
landscape and the human heart let me
give a a slightly inelegant abstract
unpacking of that I am interested in the
ways in which our minds and our moods
and our imaginations and our identities
are influenced by the textures and the
weathers and the forms and the slopes
and the curves and the creatures
remembered and actual of the places we
inhabit
I'm interested in the ways in which the
feel of the world influences our feeling
for the world
I'm these are abstract matters as I know
um so I'll I'll try to illustrate them
rather than
um
uh subject them to exegesis but one way
to illustrate them is with Thomas
because his life and work provide us
with a means of exploring some of these
ideas he was born in 1878 as you can see
two Welsh parents in London and that
anglo-welsh identity never really left
him and from a very young age he was a
walker and a writer and a Wayfarer and a
noticer and he was particularly
fascinated by paths and by those who had
followed them and by the places through
which they ran
and he possessed Keats has this lovely
phrase I'm always quoting it but I will
do again tonight Keats writes about
about possessing a pair of patient
sublunary legs and and Thomas had those
two They Carried him over literally
thousands of miles of old tracks he
walked the Ridgeway in the acne old way
and the son Helens of Wales he walked
the Pilgrim's way and he walked
um local paths on the South Downs which
he lived in lived on and loved he had
incredible stamina he could walk 30
miles in a day no problem he could walk
40 miles in a day feasibly and probably
do it for two or three days on the Trot
he's not quite up to Richard Long
standards Richard Long really is for me
one of the great athlete artists of all
time 33 miles a day for 33 days lands
ends Jonah grapes 1096 miles some
somewhere around that figure just
astonishing ability to get up and do
extraordinary distances day after day
well Thomas Thomas possessed a little of
that the earliest roads wandered like
Rivers through the land he wrote exactly
a century ago having like Rivers one
necessity to keep in motion well he used
those old ways to keep himself in motion
too because he was as I say chronically
depressed and walking was one of the
ways he could outstride his black dog so
he would cut a stick he liked Holly best
of all and he would set off along what
he called the indelible old roads worn
as he said by Hooves and feet and the
trailing staves of long dead generations
and if you hear a morbidity in that turn
of phrase he was also alert to the life
and the immediacy and the beauty of
being out walking
what he also knew was that paths run
through people as surely as they run
through places we talk these days about
ecosystem Services we talk about the
ways in which environments provide for
us well one of the ecosystem services
that environments provide for us is
metaphor landscape gives us ways of
figuring ourselves to ourselves and for
Thomas that provision of metaphor was
absolutely vital to his sense of
self-understanding so Parts connected
real locations but they also led inwards
to the self and he really began to
figure his own
Spirit if you like his own inner
landscape perhaps in topographic terms
he talked about possessing paths and
corners and Junctions and valleys and
woods and his poems and his prose are
filled with Landscapes psychological
Landscapes so he internalized the
features of the Landscapes that he lived
in and loved and he used them to map out
his Melancholy and his hopes so we might
say because I think that prepositions
matter a great deal we might say that
Thomas didn't think only about landscape
or didn't think only on landscape he
thought in it and he thought with it
and I would venture that everyone in
this room thinks to some degree in
landscape and with landscape I would say
that all of you have been significantly
shaped somebody May stand up at the end
and say no I've been entirely unexposed
to landscape in any influential way I'd
be very interested to hear that
um this is speculative but
um
I I think you have all been shaped by
places by phenomena experienced and
recollected and I wonder really what
your places are I'd be fascinated to
know the places in which to which you
return in recollection or in reality the
places that give form to your memories
and textures to your experience are they
wild are they near at hand are they
modest are they remote
are they Scottish Bays or cumbrian
valleys or Welsh peninsulas or an
English Field Corner a turn in the path
in the park a scrap of Woodland on a
city Fringe or maybe just the patch of
sky that you look up to during your
lunch hour because the birds fly across
it
are they Gardens are they copses are
they Moors are they tours are they
remote Glens or snow-covered summits I
don't know but I suspect that regardless
of their type
you will have one or several or probably
many
and there's a American writer called
Barry Lopez whose work has been a huge
influence on mine he puts it beautifully
he says we are all shaped by the sound
of wind the slant of sunlight by streams
of scent flowing faint or sharp in the
larger ocean of air well I agree with
Lopez I think we are porous to the world
I think our moods and our emotions are
configured by our surroundings in ways
that are hard to speak about but
powerful to experience we forget this to
be the case because we increasingly
spend so much of our time indoors in
climate controlled environments tapping
at our computers communicating virtually
we are increasingly disembodied but we
are still as Ted Hughes puts it very
simply and very beautifully in a
wonderful essay just called weather we
are natural barometers
well it was ideas such as these that I
wanted to explore when I started to
Begin work on the old ways the book out
of which this evening's lecture emerges
I started at about five years ago now
and it's the third in a loose Trilogy of
books that are all concerned with this
relationship of imagination and place
um they've taken me a decade they've
taken me 300 000 words of published work
they've taken me a million or more of
unpublished Words which I uh which have
ended up in various kind of waste bins
and trash files they've taken me several
thousand miles of walking and in the
course of researching them I've
experienced uh frostnip midges leeches
insomnia altitude sickness some shocking
hangovers
blisters and many many banal indignities
of travel but I've also experienced
sights and Sensations that will never
leave me and made friendships I hope
will never end